Leslie David Baker, who portrayed salesman Stanley
Hudson, is only one of five actors to appear
in every single episode of "The Office." Though
Stanley might not be the first character that fans
might associate with the series, he joins names
like Dwight Schrute, played by Rainn Wilson, and
Jim Halpert, portrayed by John Krasinski, on that
exclusive list of true Dunder Mifflin mainstays.
While "The Office" came to a close in 2013,
Baker's career remains defined in large part
by the show. In fact, Baker revealed to
Tomorrow Comes Movies at the 2018 Los
Angeles Comic-Con that he would be open to an
"Office" reunion, and he even began attempting
to finance a spin-off about Stanley through
Kickstarter in 2020. In fact, the Kickstarter
campaign ultimately raised enough money to shoot
a pilot for the series, titled "Uncle Stan." The
show aimed to focus on the relationship
between Stanley and his nephew, Lucky,
who comes to his uncle for guidance when he starts
up his own hybrid florist-motorcycle business.
Sadly, since 2020, there's been no word on
"Uncle Stan." However, like most of his co-stars,
Baker continues to enjoy the enduring passion of
fans of "The Office," even if that means indulging
in some of their less than convincing
theories that are widely shared online.
Speaking of one such, pretty unbelievable theory:
what if Stanley isn't merely a reliable supporting
player in "The Office," but actually the show's
low-key most important character? According to
an highly unlikely, yet oddly compelling
fan theory shared on Reddit, approximately
half of "The Office" episodes might take place
not in reality, but within Stanley's psyche.
According to a Reddit user who appropriately
shared their idea to the "FanTheories" subreddit,
a Season 5 episode of "The Office" titled
"Stress Relief" might be the most important
one in the show's run. In the episode's cold
open, Dwight purposefully lights a fire in a
trash can in order to set off the office's
smoke alarms and test his co-workers' fire
preparedness. In the ensuing chaos,
Stanley suffers a heart attack.
He ultimately appears to survive without
issue and is back at work after a short break.
"You will not die! Stanley,
Stanley, you will not die!"
The Redditor, however, theorizes that Stanley's
heart attack was fatal. Everything in "The Office"
from the moments following the opening credits
of "Stress Relief" to its series finale represent
Stanley in hell, and his supposed co-workers are
now demons imitating his onetime officemates.
This theory hinges on two assumptions: that
the mishaps in Dunder Mifflin are particularly
torturous for Stanley, and that the behaviors
of various characters shift significantly in
and after "Stress Relief." In the wildly
farfetched theory, the Redditor argues,
"Stanley was the person who enjoyed being at the
office the least [...] most often refusing to take
part in whatever shenanigans were being cooked
up. Hell for him is the office [...] but worse."
"I'm going to die."
One could argue, if you buy the initial theory,
that vague hints are placed throughout the show.
The most notable takes place in the Season 6
episode "Secret Santa." There's an exchange
between Stanley and Michael Scott, where Stanley
opens a gift, a scented candle, and Michael taunts
Stanley with the argument that he'll be facing
punishment for cheating on his wife. Michael says,
"A lot of fire where you're
going. Better get used to it.
You're going to H-E-L-L double hockey
sticks. Going to hell, Stanley."
To be fair, Stanley does appear to
be perpetually grumpy. Of course,
as with so many fan theories, this
one begins to collapse under scrutiny,
since plenty of moments that ensue, both
good and bad, don't concern him whatsoever.
Some other Reddit users, as usual, raised
concerns with the theory. For instance, one wrote,
"The last time I checked hell doesn't
reward people with free meatballs."
Alternatively, another user took
things to the next level and wrote,
"Creed is clearly satan if
your theory holds any validity.
Killed a guy that crossed him and took his
name and identity. No morals to speak of."
"I feel like I'm working at my own casket."
The truth is that fan theories are purely
theories. They usually don't make sense, but
they provide a fun way to re-watch old episodes.
And as it is with many fan theories, the creative
minds behind "The Office" almost certainly did
not plan most of the show's run to make it look
like it was Stanley's personal hell, particularly
since there is no such revelation contained in the
final episode. Nonetheless, a watch-through
of episodes after Stanley's heart attack,
with this theory in mind, can shed entirely new
light onto what is, for many, an old favorite.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.